how's Gomes - Kampai so today we're
gonna play some Punic pie I don't know
why I said it like that that's awkward
so when I was in USA housing I was in
New Orleans and I met this guy at the
back alley and he sold me this spicy
sauce
it's called drink this and you'll die he
made me sign a contract when I bought it
so I don't know just look at the texture
he said never eat more than a toothpick
I mean we're gonna play to boot up high
if I swear I will I will get to taste it
so let's see how it goes no swearing
gotten got it it won't be any problem
why would I ever want to swear why would
I ever want to swear I don't
I don't maybe it's better if I just
don't say anything oh I can do that way
what them didn't say anything
Devon say it I've done this part of Mali
on top there we go there we go wait for
the clown then I guess god I hate
waiting for the clown what oh my god
whoa what am I
anaconda my anaconda don't my anaconda
don't
yeah Oh God Oh God there we go don't
think I didn't forget about you there we
go we're back we're back in my black bag
my AK you still going at it is me give
up already a goddamn hmm
that's not a swear word here we go to
this fine gentleman this fine mother of
a duck gentleman that I hate more than I
hate anything in life come up here you
schmuck schmuck is not a swear word last
time I checked it's a pardon for the
French I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it
bro bro I hate em why I can never do it
[ __ ] sake god damn it all right maybe
not a spoon it's attacking me I'll dip
it in this cuz I don't want to die
all right III mean we're all gonna die
at one point all right it's dipped good
I'm dipping it good here why me oh my
god Oh what is happening what what yeah
oh god I got hiccups oh god oh god I got
what is happening to my body no it's got
it so spicy
oh god what is happening what wha what
is how yeah I think a demon is trying to
crawl yeah outside of me all right okay
it's uh Oh Oh God
what [ __ ] you ha ha ha
yeah stop somebody somebody
Am I make it stop make it stop god it's
going inside my throat that's what she
said ah ah my mass hit it tastes like I
made out with a volcano I can't progress
the spicy sauce does not level up my
skills at least I didn't swear
oh the burn mr. burns man that is
definitely worse than the ghost pepper
challenge if you take a zip out of this
you die you straight up dying I'm not
playing
oh my god that was a terrible idea oh my
god oh my god you okay
I'm sorry I'm sorry but I can't I'm
sorry uh hey Stu it's too much like for
a dyke brofist